Bir toplumu millet yapan ve o toplumun bütünlüğünü sağlayan temel unsurlardan biri milli kültürdür.
Dilimiz, tarihimiz, sanatımız, inançlarımız, gelenek ve göreneklerimiz geçmişle bugün arasında güçlü bağlar kurar.
Milli kültür, bir millete kimlik kazandıran maddi ve manevi değerlerin bütünüdür.
Milli kültürün dil, din, tarih, sanat, gelenek ve görenek gibi öğeleri kültürel bağlarımız oluşturur.
Bu bağlar aynı topluma ait bireyleri birbirine yakınlaştırır.
Kültürel bağlarımızın etkisi ile toplumda ortak değerler oluşur.
Aile birliğine önem verme, adalet, dürüstlük, sevgi, saygı, hoşgörü, yardımlaşma, vatanseverlik, özgürlük ve bağımsızlık milli değerlerimiz arasındadır.
Bu değerler davranışlarımızı yönlendirerek toplumsal ilişkileri düzenler.
Dil, bir milletin duygu ve düşüncelerini yansıtır.
Destanlar, masallar, türküler, ninniler, atasözleri ve yazılı eserler aracılığıyla
kültürel birikimimizle milli değerlerimiz kuşaktan kuşağa aktarılır.
Ortak dirimiz, milli kimliğimizin korunmasını ve aramızdaki iletişimin güçlenmesini sağlar.
Dini değerler, sevgi, hoşgörü, kardeşlik ve yardımlaşma duygularının güçlenmesine katkı sağlar.
Geçmişte kurulan bakıflar, aş evleri, kervansaraylar ve misafirhaneler ihtiyaç sahiplerine destek olmuştur.
Yunus Emre, Mevlana ve Hacı Bektaş veri gibi şahsiyetler de sevgi ve hoşgörü anlayışının yayılmasına öncülük etmiştir.
Tarih, bir milletin orta kafızasıdır.
Milletimiz, milli mücadele yıllarında bağımsızlığını korumak için, birlik içinde hareket etmiştir.
Kadın, erkek, genç ve yaşlı demeden herkes imkânları ölçüsünde mücadeleye katkı sağlamıştır.
Bu ortak mücadele, vatanseverlik, fedakârlık ve bağımsızlık değerlerini güçlendirmiştir.
Sanat eserleri bir milletin dirini, tarihini, inancını ve değerlerini yansıtır.
Geleneksel sanatlarda kullanılan renkler ve motifler yalnızca süsleme amacı taşımaz.
Sevgi, çalışkanlık ve üretkenlik gibi anlamlarda aktarır.
Bu sanatların yaşatılması, kültürel değerlerin geleceğe taşınmasını sağlar.
Gelenek ve görenekler, eskiden biri sürdürülen ve kuşaktan kuşağa aktarılan davranışlardır.
Düğünler, asker uğurlamaları, iftar sofraları, bayram ziyaretleri ve yardımlaşma gelenekleri insanları bir araya getirir.
Zimem defteri geleneğinde olduğu gibi, ihtiyaç sahiplerinin onuru korunarak yapılan yardımlar, toplumsal dayanışmayı güçlendirir.
Milli ve dini bayramlar, toplumun farklı kesimlerini ortak duygu ve değerler etrafında buluşturur.
Milli bayramlarda bağımsızlık mücadelemiz ve ortak başarılarımız hatırlanır.
Dini bayramlarda ise ziyaret, paylaşma, yardımlaşma ve barışma gelenekleri yaşatılır.
Kültürel bağların ve milli değerlerin gücü zor zamanlarda daha açık biçimde görüdür.
Afetler karşısında devletin, kurumların ve vatandaşların el ele vermesi, yardımlaşma, dayanışma, fedakarlık ve sorumluluk değerlerinin bir sonucudur.
Ortak değerler etrafında birleşen toplumlar, karşılaştıkları güçlükleri daha kolay yaşar.
Dilimiz, dinimiz, tarihimiz, sanatımız, gelenek ve göreneklerimiz bizi geçmişimize bağlar.
Bu kültürel bağlar aracılığıyla aktarılan milli değerlerimiz ise davranışlarımıza yön verir.
Ortak kültürüne ve değerlerine sahip çıkan bir toplumda güven, dayanışma ve birlik duygusu güçlenir.
Peki sen kültürel bağlarımızı ve milli değerlerimizi yaşatmak için neler yapabilirsin?